we have a voicemail from the Eggman a
convicted felon former convicted felon
weighing in on the entire convicted
felons voting thing that came up on the
show earlier this week take a listen to
the Eggman here it is I don't know why
people still think of convicted felons
can't vote I am a convicted felon I'm a
registered voter in my state here I did
register as a Republican when I got out
of prison just because I want to stand
in the radar that's a joke but it's
actually true um anyway Dave I I also
want to say the crazy thing is here that
you can be a convicted felon and run for
public office but you can't be a
convicted felon and have a load of
available jobs I applied for jobs all
the time and I know that having a my
felony conviction on there is going to
keep me from getting that job um I could
run for office though and and legislate
but I can't work at a skin bank or an
office or symbol because I robbed a bank
once you know big deal made a mistake
so felons can't vote we just can't get
jobs right yeah okay so it is it is
interesting that it would be more
difficult to become an aide to a
congressman then to be elected the
congressman based on having felony
conviction on your record and yes it's
true there's a number of different laws
depending on the state in some states as
soon as you are out of prison you have
your voting rights reinstated in some
you have your voting rights reinstated
when parole or probation have expired in
others you can you have to request that
your voting rights be reinstated but it
is true that there there is a patchwork
of laws different laws in different
states and convicted felons can
ultimately regain the right to vote on
the bonus show today the White House is
thinking about whether it makes sense to
end Social Security numbers as a sort of
default national ID very interesting
discussion we're going to have the ACLU
is also suing to increase access to the
abortion pill medical abortions
medication abortions and we will talk
about and excuse me if you're listening
during lunch cow farts are an even
bigger problem than we thought and we
will talk
not only a recent study about that but
also some new developments in terms of
mitigating methane emissions from our
bovine friends as I like to call them
all of those stories and more on the
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up as well as
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
patreon and membership now can give you
access to both the bonus show and the
commercial-free all-access pass which
includes audio and video streams of the
entire broadcast show just for you
patreon.com slash david pakman show
david pakman.com slash membership we
will speak to you on the bonus show